من جهته قال زعيم المعارضه يائير لابيد
للاذاعه الاسرائيليه ان رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو لا تهمه دوله اسرائيل وان
كل ما يهمه هو مصالحه السياسيه الشخصيه
ويجب تغييره
بسرعه وفي خبر عاجل يظهر على شاشتنا وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه تقول ان عائلات الاسرى
الاسرائيليين
ستعتمده قبله منزل نتنياهو في مدينه
قيساريا جنوب
الخليل من الخليل ينضم الينا الدكتور بلال
الشوبكي رئيس قسم العلوم السياسيه بجامعه
الخليل دكتور الشوبكي مرحبا بك دائره
الخلافات تتسع بين اعضاء مجلس
الحرب ولكن في في ال يعني في المقابل يطرح
السؤال الى اي مدى وما هو التاثير الحقيقي
لهذه الاختلافات على مسار الحرب على قطاع
غزه مساء الخير حتى تصبح يعني لهذه
الخلافات اثار حقيقيه على مسار الحرب في
قطاع غزه لابد ان يكون هناك مقابل هذه
الخلافات خطوات من قبل اولئك الذين
يختلفون مع بنيمين نتنياهو في التوجه بشان
مجريات العملي العسكريه او بشان يعني
ترتيب اولويات مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي على
اقل تقدير هذه التصريحات هي مقدمات يعني
نحن نشهد منذ حوالي اسبوعين مقدمات للحديث
عن امكانيه تفكك مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
سواء تلك المقدمه من بني جامس الذي اشار
فيها الى انه الى نبني نتنياهو عليه ان
يختار ما بين الوحده والامن وما بين
السياسه والان حديث ايزنكوت اكثر وضوحا
فيما يتعلق بالاقرار بالفشل نحن نتحدث عن
قيمه مثل هذه التصريحات في انها تاتي من
داخل داخل مجلس الحرب لانه من خارج مجلس
الحرب شهدنا الكثير من التصريحات سواء كان
من يهود باراك او من لابيد او من غيرهم من
اقطاب المعارضه الاسرائيليه هذه التصريحات
تاتي من داخل مجلس الحرب مضافا اليها انها
التصريحات منسجمه بشكل او باخر مع تصريحات
هيئه الاركان الاسرائيليه وان كانت في
سياق مختلف لكنها تصب في ذات الاتجاه وهو
ان الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه لم
تحقق شيء ولن يعني تحقق شيء اذا استمرت
القياده السياسيه ب النهج لانه اخطر تصريح
برايي كان في الاونه الاخيره ليست تصريحات
ايزنكوت لانه معروف ضمنا انه ايزن كوت
يختلف في وجهه نظره عن بنيامين نتنياهو
لكن التصريح الاخطر هو لرئيس الاركان
الاسرائيلي الذي اشار بشكل واضح الى ان
اليوم بما معناه ان اليوم التالي قد بدا
في شمال قطاع غزه ومن الواضح جدا ان هذا
اليوم التالي يشهد
ترميمات على المستوى المدني وعلى المستوى
العسكري وبالتالي اذا كانت الرؤيه
الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه تتمثل في ضروره اعتبار شمال
قطاع غزه هو النموذج الذي يمكن من خلاله
قياس انجازات الحرب الاسرائيليه فمن
الواضح ان هذه الانجازات تتاكل في ظل هذا
التقييم من قبل رئيس الاركان وفي ظل
الفجوات التي تتسع ما بين كافه الاطراف
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي يمكن ان تترجم في
نهايه المطاف الى تراجع عن العمليه
العسكريه لكنها تتطلب اولا انسحاب بيني
جانس وايزن كوت من مجلس الحرب هذا لن يعني
يعني يعني يجعل الحكومه الاسرائيليه تنهار
لكن ربما يشجع اطراف اخرى داخل حزب
الليكود وهذا برايي هو التخوف الاساسي لدى
بنيامين نتنياهو لا يتخوف بالدرجه الاولى
من ايزن كوت وبين جانس لكنه يتخوف من جلنت
وبعض احض اعضاء حزب الليكود الاسرائيلي
نعم سيد شوبكي الا تلاحظ في المقابل ان
مساله وقف اطلاق النار حتى الان يعني لم
تظهر على لسان اي من المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين ا كان من وزراء او من اعضاء
مجلس الحرب يعني الان يتحدثون عن عدم
تحقيق الاهداف عن انه لا مجاله ل عوده
المختطفين من دون التبادل او التفاهم مع
حماس لكن اي احد منهم لم يطالب لا صراحه
ولا مواربه بوقف الاطلاق
النار لمح لذلك بيني جانس قبل ايام حين
اشار انه اسرائيل يجب ان تكون مستعده لد
ثمن حتى لو كان هذا الثمن وقف اطلاق النار
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن تغيير صحيح انا
اتفق معك انه المساله ستكون صعبه على اي
قياده اسرائيلي ان يطالب الان بوقف اطلاق
النار بحكم حاله التجييش التي مرست منذ
السابع من اكتوبر لانه اي حديث عن التوقف
عن محاربه حركه حماس سيصنف في اطار اللا
وطنيه الاسرائيليه لانه تم ربط هذه الحرب
بوجود دوله الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبالتالي
التراجع عن الحرب بشكل صريح وواضح من قبل
اي قياده اسرائيلي قد يدفع او يعني قد يضع
ام في موقف محرج امام خصوم السياسيين لذلك
هم يتحدثوا بطريقه مغايره يتحدثوا بما هو
مفهوم ضمنا ان النتيجه ستكون وقف اطلاق
النار يعني حين يقول ايزنكوت او بيني جانس
ان الاولويه لاطلاق سراح المحتجزين وفي ظل
موقف الفصائل الفلسطينيه انه لن يتم اطلاق
سراح المحتجزين الا بمفاوضات على ارضيه
وقف اطلاق النار معناها انهم وصلوا الى
النتيجه التي يمكن القول فيها انهم مع وقف
اطلاق النار دون ان يعلنوا عن ذلك بشكل
واضح وصريح بالاضافه الى ذلك هناك عامل
اخر الشارع الاسرائيلي يعني الان يعني انا
كنت اتابعك وانت تقرا خبر عاجل على الشاشه
ان الاعتصام سيكون امام منزل بنيامين
نتنياهو هذه خطوه برايي جوهريه في السياق
الاسرائيلي ان المسيرات ليست امام الكنيست
ليست امام مقر الحكومه ليست امام مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي نحن نتحدث عن مسيره امام
منزل بنيامين نتنياهو بمعنى ان المجتمع
الاسرائيلي بدا يشخص هذه الازمه وبدا
يتعامل مع ان الازمه الحقيقيه مرتبطه في
شخص بنيامين نتنياهو حتى لو كان الامر
كذلك ان كان من اعضاء مجلس الحرب او بعض
الوزراء او حتى من اداره الرئيس بايدن
وبعض المشرعين الامريكيين الخلافات بدات
تظهر بقوه لكن حتى الان نتنياهو ما زال
قادرا على المضي قدما وما زال مصرا على
الذهاب نحو مزيد اي من من الحرب ويتحدث عن
اشهر طويله يعني ما هذا او ما هذه القوه
التي يستند اليها نتنياهو في مواجهه كل
هؤلاء
المعترضين ولا يستند على قوه وانما يستند
على ادراكه الى انه حتى هذه اللحظه قوى
اليمين التي تهدد او تبتزه ما زالت بحاجه
الى بنيامين نتنياهو ما زالت بحاجه الى
استمرار الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه لانه
انفضاض هذه الحكومه بمعنى تلويح بنفير
وسموت بامكانيه الانسحاب من الحكومه تلويح
براي يعني يعني ظاهري اكثر من كونه يع عكس
ايمان حقيقي بانهم قويين الى هذه الدرجه
لانه في نهايه المطاف انهيار هذه الحكومه
يعني انتخابات مبكره وفي ظل ما نقرا من
استطلاعات راي في المجتمع الاسرائيلي حظوظ
اليمين وحظوظ بنيمين نتنياهو والليكود
ضعيفه جدا لذلك يستقوي بنيمين نتنياهو
بهذا الاحساس بان اليمين ما زال بحاجه
اليه بالاضافه الى ذلك ان المسيرات في
اسرائيل او الاعتصامات في اسرائيل لم
ترتقي الى المستوى الضاغط لا ضاغط على
يعني هي مؤثره بشكل كبير لكن حتى هذه
اللحظه الى اذا لم تنتقل الى مستوى يعيق
الحركه اليوميه للمجتمع الاسرائيلي سيبقى
بنيمين نتنياهو في هذه المساحه مساحه لا
قرار